all right here with more is the host of
the co-host of the five Geraldo Rivera
and the host of Lawrence Jones cross
country LJ's with us and uh Fox News
contributor and former D.C homicide
detective Ted Williams uh thank you all
for being with us LJ
um let me start with you you watch this
tape you see this tape and I know so
many people in law enforcement and I was
looking for this Five Guys there against
one young man and obviously they have
the advantage of pulling out their stun
guns and pulling out pepper spray there
you know they're they're mad they're
angry at no time that I hear anyone say
sir sir
everybody calm down we're not going to
hurt you we're not here to hurt you we
but we do have to take into custody we
really need your cooperation tone could
mean everything I I heard nothing but
anger like real anger and you see the
physicality here we're talking about
five on one like that part I'm having a
hard time that is not the policing that
I believe officers are trained in
you know son we've done this a lot we we
review the facts the evidence and we
don't arrest the Judgment but you can't
deny what you see on tape and that and
I'm not just talking for myself I'm
talking about the officers that I've
been texting back and forth Shawn when
you brought me to the channel I've been
covering crime for a long time I know a
lot of cops talk to them on a day-to-day
basis and they're all horrified they
want to wish their condolences to the
Nichols family but Sean there were
several things in this video that stood
out to me you come to the scene out of
control out of control you disobey uh
police policy you don't just roll up on
a car like that you don't know what the
suspect could possibly have you put
yourself at risk and then you
slaughtered the suspect you started to
spray each other with with the spray
because you're not using it the right
way you use your taser the wrong way you
use your batons the wrong way you didn't
restrain the suspect the right way I
mean that's just basic police protocol
call and then I just can't get past the
fact that you held the suspect up and
you beat them you took turns you use
your baton in the wrong way and then I
just can't help but be annoyed by the
fact that they fist bumped at the end so
there was many layers to this Basic
Police protocol was broken right here
they were on a power trip and he didn't
have to die that night he was crying out
for his mom again they they have the
right to defend themselves in the court
of law but just from a tactics
standpoint basically police protocol
Sean I started off when I was 16 years
old as a police explorer I know protocol
and they broke every rule in the book
you know Geraldo I you LJ's right he's
crying for his mom at one point he's
he's literally getting punched and
kicked and pepper sprayed uh and tasered
and you know there's five cops there
they're supposed to be the trained
Professionals in in a situation look he
was obviously scared uh obviously felt
they were being overly aggressive from
from the get-go and said so hey guys
there's a lot going on here early on
that there was nobody there that tried
to even defuse it and then you know to
watch this one cop just come walking in
disgusted and just kick this kid in the
head not once but twice you know a Kick
In The Head kills people Geraldo
mm-hmm
you know show on the
this horse and five cops this was a wolf
pack this was a cowardly sadistic
bunch of brutes
who who murdered a man right before our
very eyes that's the most Eerie thing
about it you you're watching a dead man
screaming for his mother I mean it is
outrageous it is the most pathetic thing
I've ever seen and where the hell was a
police Sergeant where was a supervisor
you have these five Macho
cops out there who I don't know how much
training they had
they're they're Instinct was to lash out
was to was to inflict pain was to
torture this young man to death it is
really it makes me want to puke it is
the most sickening thing I've ever
seen in terms of police brutality and
and
the way that the one cop kind of winds
up and then goes 10 15 feet to land a
blow a kick
to the victim's head and then another
kick and then the other one takes a turn
and he's obviously
defenseless
I mean it is it is really I I when I
first heard the charges of murder 2 I
said wow that's pretty serious this
early in the game but when you see this
it is clear that this was Reckless
disregard for human life
this is this is murder two at least you
know Ted Williams I I like Geraldo like
LJ I know a lot of police officers and
I'm watching and I I see five cops
around him and I find it almost
spectacularly
unbelievable to me that five trained
officers obviously lacking in a lot of
training that they can't cuff one young
man and they can't get control of the
situation and they all let the seemingly
all of them most of them anyway let the
tempers get the better of them they took
it so personally no there was no attempt
to defuse the situation in any way
um which I believe easily could have
been done there was even simple
Jiu Jitsu 101 Maneuvers could have you
know enabled the police to to easily
cuff this guy but none of them seem to
have any of that training at all the
only training that that they seem to be
TR they only seem to be trained to be
angry and I'm not sure where the anger
came from they're always going to be
people during an arrest that don't want
to be arrested that is part of the job
but them doing it professionally has to
happen that didn't happen here
why
what you asked a excellent question you
have to first go back and ask where was
the humanity of these police officers
the first thing we see in the first
video they're coming up aggressively to
this man's call and they don't talk to
the man they rip him out of his
automobile and they immediately start
pepper spraying him and then Sean if you
go to the video four that was on the
lamp post you see how inhumane these
officers are they're kicking this man in
the head they're beating them they're
saying show me your hands or give me
your hands while they're still the man
is in pain and he's calling for his
mother and he says initially when they
took him out of that course on he said
why I didn't do anything wrong I didn't
do anything wrong or Sean this is just
terribly outrageous but Sean let me make
sure we are clear here
black men and women who are dead and
children are crying from the grave we
didn't do anything they this is an
excellent example unfortunately what has
happened to black people throughout the
history of this country and I'm very
very upset about these four or five
black officers black officers treating
another black man the way they treated
this man this was you don't even treat a
dog this way this was just unhumane and
I think Geraldo is right where in the
hell was the supervisor why wasn't the
supervisor there on the scene
supervising this situation what you have
to ask yourself
but Ted there wasn't one of these
officers that didn't have enough sense
training to stand back objectively
realize everyone's getting out of
control call for calm let their
professionalism take over talk to the
the suspect talk them down talk calmly
say it's it's got to be all right nobody
wants to get hurt here we want to make
sure that we we take care of you as well
we have our job to do help us do our job
tone Cadence that matters in a moment
like that
crime scene
and can I just say this because I think
it's important to say this cops are the
only profession that are judged by the
individuals the very few that do the
wrong thing they didn't just steal
someone's life they set the profession
back prepare for months of Rage prepare
for cops to be demonized over the
actions of these people they took this
man's life the other cops the 95 percent
that go out there and put a badge on
every single day you got to remember son
we're already dealing with limited
people in the profession way to go way
to set us back because now we're gonna
have to deal with this let me go some
people stepping back as a result of this
is what's going on in the profession
right now we've got a lot of experienced
police officers who are leaving the
profession and they're leaving it and
you've got these inexperienced cops out
there that are doing the job this is
what's also going on in the profession
and yes you're right Lawrence this sets
the profession back they're good men and
women who put that uniform on every day
and go out here and Serve and Protect
the communities these officers do not
deserve to wear the uniform of Memphis
Tennessee
Geraldo in this particular case the the
suspect was African-American the five
cops involved African-Americans uh
there's a so-called News Network it's a
comedy channel I guess you have van
Jones saying that the police that killed
Tyree Nichols were black but they might
still have been driven by racism he says
black people are not immune to
anti-black messages one of the sad facts
about anti-black racism is that black
people ourselves are not immune to its
pernicious effects and society's message
that black people are inferior unworthy
and dangerous is pervasive and it's not
just van Jones it's the communication
workers of America it's MPR it's Al
Sharpton it's you know the attorney Ben
Crump who or our colleague jono uh uh
talked to earlier tonight
um where does that that come from here
you know Sean Memphis Tennessee is where
tragically in April 1968 Martin Luther
King was assassinated
since then the city has been roiled by
racial tension it is now predominantly
black City with soaring crime the police
force is
consistently under man they are
desperate for officers they are
searching for recruits everywhere I
don't know whether they've relaxed their
standards or what the result is all I
know is what my eyes tell me after a
half century in this business dealing
with Law and Order and and cops of all
of all colors
what I see here you know are men who are
just they they reduce themselves to
Savage to I use the term wolf pack
earlier I this it was so uncontrolled it
was so undisciplined it was so
slanderously unprofessional and Lawrence
is right and Ted is Ted's anguish is is
poignant and Lawrence is right about
setting back the shortage that we have
now with cops after George Floyd and and
all these other incidents that have
happened is so chronic what the result
of this will be is that that
neighborhood will be more resentful of
the cops there will be more crime there
will be harder for them to recruit
officers this is a this is a body blow
to Law and Order to race relations this
is really awful but if the protesters
use this as an excuse me
when you say it's a body blow or
although when you say it's a body blow
to racism where's the racial component
here now there are good cops and there
are bad cops and to me it has nothing to
do with race there are professional cops
as as Ted said as LJ said as you said
that get up put on that uniform they
know they're risking their lives but
they go to work every day to serve their
communities and protect their
communities the that transcends race to
me and in this case there are just so
many people trying to make this racial
is this case racial because I don't see
it
the the point is Sean I I agree that
what this does is strip race from the
question of police training and police
brutality but you cannot avoid
the reality that these were five black
men young black men Macho
spree decor
filled with verb and grit that's not
what I mean they joined the police force
is this right now look what they have
done but look look but my point is this
look what they have done now what look
what they have done the blow that they
let me go to LJ have struck to the
community it's a it's let me let me let
me ask you the same question the racial
components the humanity issue it's about
sorry I'm sorry uh LJ go ahead
Manatee Susanna I I see where you're
going with it this is not valid that
having value for human life this doesn't
have to go this way whether he resisted
or not they didn't value his life and
apparently they didn't value their own
life the way that they showed up to the
scene you don't go up to a car that way
that's Basic Police 101. and look I
agree with my colleague Ted training is
an issue within some of the police
departments right now especially when it
comes to
um the the numbers that we have right
now but let's not be confused here these
gentlemen were a part of elite unit the
Scorpions okay that is equivalent to New
York City's anti-crime unit it takes
grit to be on there okay I understand
the job that they have to do which is
why they should have had the proper
training to conduct that stop and they
didn't do it the right way it was
selfish on multiple levels to the cops
that served that do the job the right
way
but it's also if we want to if since
people want to put race in in this Sean
every black man knows about the talk
that our father gives us what you're
supposed to do when you're stopped by a
police officer we have gentlemen that
got the talk
as well as our black police officers so
they just didn't value life they didn't
care about any of that in that moment
all right LJ thank you uh Ted Williams
thank you for although thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else